[Music]
good morning Hank it's April 6th
good Friday well it's good Friday for me
for you it's just regular heathen Friday
thank you will no doubt note that the
zit has not gone away I was going to
take good Friday off but then at the end
of your puppet show yesterday you said
John we'll see you tomorrow and I don't
like to disappoint you so here it is
tomorrow and you're seeing me but I'm so
tired let's see what the commenters have
to say about this subject comment your
query writes hey I just wanted to say
that you guys are awesome I did have one
suggestion however you both seem and I
could be wrong to be a bit down and not
really wanting to make your bi daily
videos I propose that you have every
eighth week off to regenerate your humor
and energy keep up the good work oh I
see what you're trying to do you're
trying to tempt me you're probably a
popular person and you're scared because
you see what we're doing you see what
the nerdfighters are accomplishing and
it worries you so you want us to take
every eight week off I'll admit it's an
attractive idea but does injustice take
every eighth week off does despair take
every eighth week off does global
warming take every eighth week off does
Dick Cheney take every eighth week off
from intentionally misleading the
American people about the relationship
between Saddam Hussein and Al Qaeda does
orbital cellulitis take every eighth
week off does Us Weekly take every
eighth week off does suck take every
eighth week off no and nor shall we
I'm an English literature nerdfighter I
don't need to take days off to recharge
I just go to my room read a couple
stanzas of the wasteland and I'm good to
go we will stand and fight all year long
except for weekends and occasional
holidays nerdfighters it reminds me of
something that ghetto boys once said
real gangsta-ass nerdfighters don't run
from nothing because real gangsta-ass
nerdfighters can't run fast
good news Hank the foundation to
decrease suck is on the March we've just
made our first gift of $100 to one kid
one world an organization that helps
refugees in Africa thanks to all the
contributors including most notably
you Hank in other news congratulations
on completing your punishment via sock
puppet theatre
I would like to say though that as
humiliating as those stories were they
are not nearly humiliating enough I
think it's important that all
Brotherhood 2.0 viewers see the picture
that you put up in comments oh my god
the plain fact of the matter Hank is
that it's one thing to look at a sock
puppet that is ostensibly wearing
lipstick and eyeshadow and it's quite
another thing to look at Hank green
wearing black lipstick and eyeshadow can
we see it again please it's true that I
like to cure a lot that I was known to
occasionally prowl the halls of Winter
Park High School in ninth grade while
wearing eyeliner but I had the good
sense never to let myself be
photographed can we just do it one more
time people who might not have been
watching earlier maybe you went out to
get a sandwich or something and back
there is duh
I love it thank you God most for this
amazing picture of Hank Hank I'll see
you on Monday Happy Easter